ciao a tutti i benvenuti sono i tra
storici dove questo canale si chiamerà
anita storici perché sto facendo sempre
video in cui dobbiamo fare silenzio
allora in questo video andrò a fare uno
scherzo a vitale una scherzo che voglio
farli da tanto tempo sto parlando piano
perché lui sta dormendo in camera anche
se berlino
sto facendo un sacco di casino parlo se
chiedo qualcosa quindi sta facendo
casino comunque come questo scherzo alla
loro praticamente mentre pitale dorme
non vi preoccupate perché quando vitale
dorme neanche le cannonate lo svegliano
mente ho comprato una cosa su amazon
ora ve la faccio vedere subito e fin qua
allora ho comprato con il tacco
indovinate che cosa nei commenti ridiamo
chi riesce a indovinare prima che la pro
sta qua sopra sia scritto rosso ma mi sa
che hanno sbagliato ha sbagliato colore
ma forse è ancora meglio con questo
colore
guardate un po tonto una crema una
pomata in realtà è una tinta per capelli
è una tinta per capelli e appunto qua
c'è scritto rosso marlino cioè lei non
mi ascolta c'è scritto rosso è infatti
lavoro presa rosa però guardate un po
che colore
[Musica]
mantova camera come ti permetti ricadere
così guardati un po che colore questo
siccome poi a me sembra un fucsia viola
non rosso decisamente non so come hanno
scritto rosso se non è per niente rosso
o forse sono io daltonica questa cremo
in pratica è una crema colorante per
capelli
io cosa farò proverò a fare sperando che
evitate non si sveglia mentre dorme
io andrò a metterli questa crema nei
capelli non vedo l'ora di vederlo clicca
per i viola però dobbiamo stare super
attenti a non svegliarlo appunto per
fortuna vitale non si sveglia appunto
nemmeno con le cannonate quindi non
penso che si sveglierà ma dobbiamo stare
molto attenti
sarà poi doc di colori capelli io non
gli dirò niente e cercherò di far
lievitare gli specchi perché voce che
non se ne accorga subito che c'era
ancora più divertente vederlo con i
capelli bianchi
non so se funziona e altri che se si
sveglia mi dirà ma che stai facendo e
speriamo che funzioni
lasciate un bel mi piace e se volete
vedere altri scherzi a vitale
consigliatemi lì pure nei commenti se
questo video raggiunge i 40 mila mi
piace li farò un altro scherzo e
consigliate miss che scherzo fargli nei
commenti siete pronti ora andiamo
innanzitutto a vedere se sta ancora
dormendo
spero di sì ma non sento nessun rumore
quindi penso di sì ok vediamo
messi non mi raccomando ai clienti ho
capito ma il trend
[Musica]
prometto ancora per molto
ok ragazzi a dormendo l'unico dubbio che
mi è venuto e che se io li metto tutto
questo colorante fucsia va a macchiare
la il cuscino e non vuole che macchia il
cuscino quindi vado a prendere per
strumenti un asciugamano così sarà un po
difficile metterlo ma non voglio
mangiare il cuscino altrimenti è un
disastro non so neanche se si lava via
questa cosa quindi vado a prendere
lasciare ok ragazzi è così allora per
prima cosa
metterò questa fuga ma sperano che lo si
svegli perché altrimenti faccio un
disastro con questo colorante quindi
andiamo fate il tifo per me
[Musica]
ok ragazzi abbiamo fatto ho dato fa con
di prodotto e sommesso tipo mezz'ora per
tutti aiuta le mani perché sia davvero
una tinta per monitare perché un sito di
palloni ma la mia ma questo anno il gelo
di roma capitale
ora si svegli e io cercherò di fare in
modo che non si guardi allo specchio
[Musica]
buongiorno hai dormito bene ho mal di
testa
come mai
[Musica]
e andiamo subito a fare colazione
sto facendo un blog per prendere una
migliore inquadratura
andiamo subito però in pratica questo
prodotto funziona così solo io mi posso
guardare nella camera
quindi hai dormito bene niente
posso mangiare tutto quello che voglio
no come allora voglio un cornetto un kit
kat
biscotti al cioccolato esclusioni
promette mi prometti biscotti per
cornetto caffè ma pronto a pranzo su
carmen da oggi dieta di cui non sapeva
di sci disinvolti siamo pro vita
dobbiamo portare a qualcosa da mangiare
che dobbiamo portare il bulino a spasso
berlino berlino che i pezzi del tuo
padroncino l'altro mi bello oggi che mi
porto strano ma genietto berlino perché
la ragazza intorno a questo momento non
mi ha ascoltato oggi berlino piloti
parti posso bere un caffè nel frattempo
bisogna studiare come se vi ricordate
non piace libera per ciò che è successo
questo è un po paura oggi cosa c'è chi
pellicola paura come mai ho paura di
teologi berlino risolvo buono mi sta
mancando tutte le mani che sto facendo
non posso guardare che cosa c'è che cosa
ha risposto con alain armadio e si parla
abbastanza perché un altro stato
[Musica]
chi c'è
è meglio per te è solo un alcuna
challenge sulla cibo e la nuova
challenge sarà sicuramente impegni e non
ho imparato tutto il giorno berlino
si viaggia nuovo faceva paura per non
dover natura colore di capelli è
successo m
guardatemi tre premi su visto pensavo di
essermi rotto la testa camerata la testa
hai vissuto questa cosa possa capirlo e
via la durissima e marcello no e
colorate e colorante per via arrivando
con i capelli rosa detto no come
l'occhio bellissimo nazioni dopo nissimo
di me ma dico la verità mi piacciono un
po non troverà si celebri la salita di
no
oddio che paura non è fatto ma perché mi
dei fatti tutte lenzoni potevi farti con
una pettinatura tutta la musica sognarli
aver mai a selettiva no mi sono già
sporcava dai campi di gara troppo duri
non ce la faccio altro barbato 6 gen
durito
allora fatemi 3 benefico per il secondo
noi vi stanno benissimo chi è che
secondo me se mettere i commenti
preferito evitare con i capelli normali
noiosi ottani catelli però secondo me lo
dovevi fare meglio
secondo me li faccio bello e paura tra
turisti non è mai il problema è problema
c'è solo il mani rosse già ma diventa
poco mi faccio non diventi rimanere
corti per me detto e se mettono a
testare della lavatrice liquami
esportato tutto quindi vuol dire che
questo mi rimarrà qui sulla fronte come
si può essere ma le leggi l'istruzione
primaria
[Musica]
piace 40 per i nuovi capelli rosa sempre
detto che berlino è rimasto scioccato
che dice meglio che dormo così mi
sveglia il mio padre un chilo sarà di
nuovo normale
ti piace molto tenero almeno per una
settimana non si può più dormire in
santa pace
allora ti è piaciuto questo scherzetto
molto vedi come sapete con i capelli
rosa secondo me sei super bene tu prendi
lasciarli così mi sembra un personaggio
dei cartoni è vero palla di fuoco per
poterli scrivete nei commenti
secondo voi stanno bene i capelli rosa
vitale secondo me ti stanno bene
dovrete lasciarle quasi gallina mare e
avvenuti aspettava tanto visto che mi si
sporcavano le mani su youtube da no
lasciatemi il viaggio se volete vedere
altri scherzetti e ii verdi del bene chi
ride ultimo fatemi sapere se volete che
faccia la stessa scherzetto ad anita
tanto io me ne accorgono di per molti
come berlino ma che mai anche berlino
vuole salutarvi ciao
ora vi lasciamo qua quattro cartellini
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite